the FBI says Americans should look out
for terror attacks on Monday they said
they would do it but they're so busy
with Hillary's emails from 2009 you know
a terrorist attack that would be such a
nightmare scenario to watch terrorists
ruin our election after all the work
Russia has put into doing that I mean
this is I know this is a comedy show and
I'm gonna try to keep it on that level
but it's not funny
there is a slow-moving right-wing coup
going on media do your job
the FBI has become politicized they call
they're calling it trump land iya
there's a faction in it that is
politicized and trying to sabotage
Hillary's campaign because they're
convinced that she is the devil now is
it really surprising that guys in a
building named after J Edgar Hoover have
issues with women perhaps not but we
have reached peak insanity here the
Russians are creating fake documents to
discredit the Hillary campaign and the
Trump campaign tweets them out as if
they are real Republicans are trying to
elect a sexually assaulting psychopath
who is if not a Russian agent
unwittingly working as one and people in
America are saying well it's better than
Hillary no it's that
[Applause]